I was raped at gunpoint at work and they
still asked me what I had on as though
that matters as though that matters it's
it's the language that we use it's the
lack of media attention it's the lack of
resources 71
000 black girls under 17 went missing in
2021 and they were they were identified
as runaways nine out of ten were
identified as runways if you're
identified as a runaway no Amber Alert
or no no no law enforcement attention
nothing having covered Gabby potito on
the ground and knowing that this has
brought more awareness to that issue
we're talking about it more than I could
ever recall as a journalist how much do
you think the show has helped with that
conversation I mean we've only been out
a few days
um but already the response has been
enormous and we have heard from every
organization
that does this work